hello and welcome to footnotes as per
the usual I'm here to recap the most
ravishing in language and ideas from the
last week of Wired first up today we're
going off the rails wyd signs posted a
live feed of two comets passing each
other with reporter at a man referring
to them as celestial drifters so
drifters are different from vagrants and
that they may be looking for work
whereas vagrants resort to begging
comets in this sense are drifting with
the full-time job of looking awesome and
tearing up ever since we shunned our
nomadic tendencies and settled in cities
that have been wandering holdouts but it
was the American hobo that truly
romanticized the freedom in drifting
this hobo is a drifter who was willing
to work as opposed to a who is not
and the hobos classic symbol is the
bindle with relatively rich hobos
sporting the exceedingly rare triple
decker bindle though the term hobo did
not emerge until the turn of the 20th
century these drifters began writing
freight trains extensively after the
Civil War they were looking for work or
running away from the women they
insincerely promised to marry if they
survived the war and there are
ostracized from the get-go
many train riding hobos were political
radicals and while they worked for an
honest wage some also stole and they
were constantly hounded by railroad
guards known as Bulls who unfortunately
never fell for the red blanket trick huh
Boing peaked in the Great Depression and
continues to this day there's even a
hobo convention in Britt Iowa come for
the ugly shoe contest stay for the
schwag
next up double your pleasure double your
death that's the statement of the word
doppelganger and a piece on video game
guru Peter Molyneux in the November
issue of the magazine in folklore your
doppelganger is a paranormal exact copy
of yourself it comes from the German
meaning double walker or go
traditionally senior doppelganger is a
bad omen typically of impending death
sometimes at the hands of Chuck Norris I
said stay down many ostensibly sane
historical figures have reported seeing
their doppelgangers for instance Abe
Lincoln once said that he looked in the
mirror and saw another face next to his
reflection complete with sick nasty hat
and it's no wonder the connotation with
doppelgangers is a bad one seeing
somebody who looks even a little bit
like us elicits a sort of discomfort
because it challenges our sense of
identity except if you're under 21 and
have an older cousin who looks like you
then it's just convenient the
doppelganger horror was captured
masterfully in the classic Twilight Zone
episode mirror image in which a woman
sees her doppelganger and has an
existential breakdown in a bus station
which is where I prefer to experience my
emotional collapse she suggests that her
doppelganger is from another plane of
existence and has come to replace her
but if the laws of quantum physics are
correct there could be an infinite
number of alternate universes with an
infinite number of versions of you
slightly different from each other I
just hope the one that comes to replace
me has bigger muscles and a beard and a
triple bindle